are you looking to kill some time and
are all out of ideas
well from washing clothes to running
backwards these guys have become
experts in goofing off here are four
unique ways to spend that extra time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
when i'm running backwards it almost
feels like i'm flying
because it's such a different visual
perspective
seeing how far i've gone as opposed to
how far i need to go
when you're going backwards you can
really just take a step back literally
and enjoy what you're doing
[Music]
hi i'm aaron yoder i'm a backwards
runner i have the
world record for the fastest mile ran
backwards
my fastest backwards smile time is 5
minutes
and 54 seconds
i've been running ford for over 20 years
i started running competitively when i
was in
elementary school and then ran on
scholarship during
my early 20s
i ran so much that i sustained a knee
injury
my doctor told me to stop running and i
really didn't want to stop
so i knew i had to make some sort of
change
[Music]
retro running or backwards running is
where you're literally just running in
reverse
and there's no impact on my knee i
run backwards everywhere i run backwards
on the treadmill i run backwards on
the track and also out on country roads
backwards running feels great on my knee
i don't feel anything
which is a reason why i really enjoy it
[Music]
stay tall knee up there we go good job
when i'm coaching my track team i
occasionally have them run backwards
as to enhance and diversify their
training workouts
onward and upward good job way to go
good warm up there there's more
backwards runners out there than one
would think there are hundreds if not
thousands of people that decide to run
in reverse
the last world championships there were
over 20 countries represented
and close to 200 athletes
backwards running has allowed me to see
things in a little bit different
perspective in a world where everyone
goes forward
and i'm going backwards it's really
allowed me to
just get back to competing against
myself
and not be so concerned what other
people are doing i found great
gratification
in the fact that i'm just competing
against
my own shadow
[Music]
everybody's got their favorite part of
the cycle there are people who love the
wash they love the rinse or the spin
or the drain i'm a spin guy i love the
spin
there it goes my name is john charles
and i'm a washer collector
uh enthusiast laundry day
the club got started around 1987 i think
and now we have like 3 000 members from
all over the world
when we get together for wash-ins you do
laundry till like four in the morning
you do your margaritas and your laundry
together
the laundry to laundry laundry
we watch the cycles you'll see a lot of
us just stand there and watch the whole
cycle go through
oh my god everywhere all 3 000 of us
come in with a story like i thought it
was the only one i thought it was the
only person
in the world that did this
[Music]
in the collection i've got 59 machines
and i've got 22 hooked up and running
down here in the basement
i have a good representation of
everything that was made
from 1938 to today and i take them all
apart and i restore them because i want
to know how everything works inside the
machine
and then the laundry is for me it's sort
of like the frosting on the cake
these machines represent a lot of ways
of doing things in each decade that
change
that we no longer do and i think it's
something that should be preserved for
other people if we can get them
interested
i just can't go to a cocktail party say
how's your washer doing they look at me
like i was crazy
but i can get together with these guys
let my hair down
it's just so much fun to be able to have
a conversation about it because i know
laundry's a chore for everybody else but
for us
it's it's play collecting milk bottles
following brown road signs spotting
village water pumps
taking pictures of tombstones
appreciating roundabouts
these are dull things to do aren't they
welcome to the dell men's club
[Music]
i am grover click i'm assistant vice
president of the dull men's club and one
of its founders
the knowledge club is a group that get
together to celebrate the ordinary
yeah began in the 1980s a long time ago
we began in in new york city and later
i moved to london and the dull men's
club followed me and it's grown
here in england as well it's got members
both in england
and america and across the world the
last time we did a roundup putting all
things together it looked like we had
about 5 000 members
so here are the people that do things
that some people think are dull
here's steve i'm a mobile collector i
have some
20 000 milpoles from not just the uk but
all over the world
germany france south africa hong kong
portugal i've got iranian bottles
i don't like milk at all i just don't
like it
sorry and we have some women that are
interested in the dell men's club
here's amanda my quirky hobby is
randomly following brown tourist signs
yep you heard her right
i get inspired to turn off the road
whenever i see one i find it very hard
not to
i follow brown signs around the uk and
indeed
the whole world so i've now been to
thousands and thousands we also have a
member that appreciates
roundabouts i'm kevin
and i'm the president of the uk
roundabouts appreciation society
also known as lord of the rings that's
my official title
i have taken thousands of pictures of
roundabouts even when i'm abroad on
holiday
i know a lot of people would find my
hobby quite dull
but it's bright being dull it's sexy
being dull
and next is a member that is just dying
to get into a
graveyard
i'm a tomb traveler and i take pictures
of famous graves
around the globe probably over the years
four or five hundred
on various parts of the world kennedy
martin luther king bruce lee and brandon
lee elvis presley
ludwig van beethoven charlie chaplin
well i don't feel that i'm a dull man
but
people have said that but i prefer to
think that i've got a rounded i'll be an
interest it takes my mind away from work
and we have dick who's spotting village
water pumps and it all came about to
accident ten years ago
somebody pointed out a tiny little pump
by the side of the road
and almost every village you went
through i'd see there's a pump i'm going
to
slam the brakes on and jump out and take
a picture of the pump
it's okay to be dull there are a lot of
studies being done now that
boredom has got benefits we're not so
interested in the glitz and glam
we're quite happy with simple things in
life
you